هؤلاء الناس يتجادلون حول
مسلم.بعض أولئك الذين فروا مما تسميه الأمم المتحدة
إبادة جماعية تريد حكومة ميانمار
منك أن تصدق أنه لم يحدث أبدًا
أهميتنا في إنقاذ الأرواح مثلما
نؤثر على حياتنا لمقابلة هؤلاء الأشخاص ، فقد
استغرق الأمر عدة أيام ومهزلة
ركوب القارب للوصول إلى هذا الجزء من "
ولاية ميانمار الغربية النائية"
بحيث لا يُسمح للأجانب بدخول هذا
الجزء من النوع "الطريقة الوحيدة التي نتواجد بها هنا
هي بمرافقة حكومية ،
حيث يتم أخذنا فقط حيثما تريدنا السلطات
للذهاب إلى محطتنا الأولى ، القرية
الهندية هناك اعتاد أن يكون هناك أكثر من ستة
آلاف صف مفصلي يعيشون هنا ، إنه
صف هانجا ، وجودهم الآن جميعًا ولكن تم
محوه بهذه الطريقة ، حسنًا ، شكرًا لك ،
هذا ما تبقى من الصف مفصل
قرية كانت هنا
إنه متضخم تمامًا ، من الصعب معرفة أنه
كان هناك أي هياكل هنا في أي وقت ،
فإن القرائن الوحيدة التي لدينا على العنف
الذي حدث هنا هي أشجار مثل هذه الأشجار
التي لا تزال بعد عام تحمل
آثار الحرائق التي اندلعت  في
هذه القرية على الأرض ،
قالت الحكومة إن قواتها ردت
على هجمات إرهابية مفصلية هنا في عام
2017 ، لكن هذا المفصل
أحرق منازلهم فقط
البوذيين المتكئين المحليين الآن ،
يدعم هذا الرجل القصة
التي بدأت مفصلات الصفوف تهدد الجيش  يقول إن
المسلمين أعلنوا أنهم سيقيمون
احتفالًا بذبح
وطهي الجنود والناس المتكئين على الرغم من أن
الأدلة الواضحة تشير إلى أن الخلاف كان
يتوقف على من كانوا الضحايا الرئيسيين
لمذبحة عشرة روجان دجيمون تم
اختراقها وقتلها جنود ميانمار.
مذبحة اعترف بها الجيش
وسُجن صحفيان من رويترز
بسبب تحقيقهما في الأمم المتحدة وتقول إن
العديد من الرجال والنساء والأطفال
قُتلوا بوحشية هنا بالإضافة
إلى أن الرحلة ستستمر عبر أرض قاحلة تبدو
منطقية عندما
تتذكر أن الأمم المتحدة تقول سبعمائة و
عشرين ألف روجان جيف قاد عندما
اندلع العنف العام الماضي تقرير كامل للأمم المتحدة
يوثق كيف الجيش
والجماعات المحلية المنخرطة في عمليات تعذيب
واغتصاب وقتل ما لا يقل عن 10000 شخص
للتخلص من جماعة الروجا التي
يعتبرها كثيرون وأوسع نطاقًا في ميانمار
غير مواطنين غير بشر ، لذا هل تستمرون في الادعاء
بأن الإبادة الجماعية لم تحدث في
ولاية راخين خلال الحادث  كان هناك بعض
الضرر فيما يتعلق بالجيش ، لقد فعلوا
كل شيء ضمن القانون لا يمكننا
التعليق على ما إذا كان صحيحًا أم
خاطئًا ، السؤال بسيط جدًا ، هل
تعتقد أن الإبادة الجماعية حدثت هنا أم
لا ، أقول إن الإبادة الجماعية لم تحدث
الزعيم المدني في ميانمار
كما نفت أونغ سان سو تشي الحائزة على جائزة نوبل للسلام حدوث
إبادة جماعية ، وتقول حكومتها إنها
مستعدة لإعادة اللاجئين المفصولين
مثل هؤلاء العالقين في منطقة حرام
أُجبروا على الخروج من ميانمار ولم يُسمح لهم
بعبور الحدود إلى بنغلاديش ،
حيث ظلوا مقيمين جزئيًا بسبب ذلك.
القوات الأمنية التي ستشرف على
عودتهم هم من نفس الأشخاص
المتهمين بتنفيذ القتل في
المقام الأول الظروف داخل
ذلك المخيم واضحة.  أمر مروع للغاية أنه
لا توجد إمكانية للوصول إلى التعليم ، ولا رعاية صحية ، ولا يوجد
طعام للكهرباء نادر ، ومع ذلك لا يزالون
يفضلون أن يكونوا على هذا الجانب من
السياج بدلاً من هذا لأنهم
يخشون العودة قد
تستمر ميانمار في إنكار التطهير العرقي
ولكن  الأدلة التي جمعتها الأمم المتحدة
وآخرين تطغى على
الرحلة التي ترعاها الحكومة ولا تفعل شيئًا
لتغيير هذه الحقيقة